these are protein bars filled with
crickets yes
crickets well like a flower to be exact
you're here to watch us eat them aren't
you you're here to watch a squirm and
gag I hate to break it to you but this
isn't one of those videos what we're
actually here to say is that you'll soon
be eating crickets because well you have
no choice the problem is our species
continues to grow rapidly while the size
of our planet stays the same but here at
intimal farms in Ontario Canada they're
working on a six-legged solution the
whole concept the whole idea behind
insect farming is the planet can only
produce so much grain then we need to
turn that grain into protein crickets
are 10 times more efficient than cattle
on grain usage and over a hundred times
more efficient than cattle for water
usage yeah okay that is pretty gross but
the truth is people have been eating
crickets all over the world for
millennia and since eating crickets is
great for the planet we better get with
the program but how does an insect end
up in a protein bar
the farming starts either with the
cricket or the egg that's a
philosophical question we haven't
answered yet our operation lays eggs
every day and we have hatchlings every
day after the eggs hatch in an incubator
the farmers move the youngins to egg
flats after the hatchery we take them
into the finishing rooms where they're
set up with ample space it's pretty much
like a free-range situation and they
have full access to food and water 24
hours a day
free-range cricket that's good but the
freedom is short-lived
once the farmers are ready to harvest
they euthanize the critical gas and send
them to a processing facility down the
road they go into the oven where they
spend about two and a half hours at 220
degrees Fahrenheit they come out fully
roasted and with almost zero percent
humidity then it's time to grind the
crickets into flour and in Tomo can make
a whole lot of powder it keeps around
100 million crickets and produces 1,500
pounds of flour every week and as
investment continues to rise
cricket products are popping up all over
the place but the question is does it
taste okay well there's tons of other
things with out legs in the bar so how
about just a good old cricket
ah did you cover your eyes instead of
your nose
Danica did make one of those videos
didn't weight extra limbs and wings